make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we're covering x-men Fantastic Four
in number one now this is not the versus
series right the x-men Fantastic Four
versus comic was a four-part comic alpha
back in 1987 this is different this is
doesn't really seem like a versus comic
so much as not even really a team-up
just kind of two teams who were there
now it could lead into a versus event
right but I think it's one of those
instances where Marvel's kind of looking
back to order story seen their
popularity and kind of bringing him back
which is really what's been happening
with with CB Sapolsky as editor-in-chief
right it's really turned into one of
these things where Marvel's kind of
looking at like all the types of stories
that found them success in the past and
then just like let's just kind of like
try to recreate those or modify those
wherever the case is and bring them into
the modern era which is a smart move it
kind of makes sense right but with
Franklin Richards and with this story it
can go one of two ways right it could be
really really good or it could be
terrible right it really kind of depends
but it's Chip sadarski who's writing it
so I've got full faith the funny thing
about this and this is this is really
where all those kind of picks up is
essentially you've got like Kitty Pryde
right now for those guys who were
following what's going on and Dawn of X
Kitty Pryde is currently the Red Queen
basically a pirate and she looks amazing
as a pirate right like with the whole
like that Danah and like the coat and
all that kind of stuff the issue with
this is she's basically been summoned to
Krakow
right now remember kitty pryde for
whatever reason is not able to access
the Kirk Owen gates right she cannot
pass through the gates the way the
mutants normally do so essentially she
kind of has to take the long way around
but the idea behind this is that she's
been summoned by Charles Xavier and
Magneto and the reason why is because
they're finally getting to the point
where they're trying to call in Franklin
Richards now there's a couple reasons
for why this is being done right like
the surface explanation offered by
Charles Xavier is well he's one of us
and he belongs among his own brethren
the reality of this is it's a power play
that's really all it is right it's just
is a Power Move by Charles Xavier in and
Magneto not so far in to say like we
have control we can do what we want but
in the sense that if all of you guys
know Franklin Richards is a heavy hitter
the power he will possess when he
becomes an adult and this was covered
both and Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four and Mark Wade's a history of the
Marvel Universe the time will come
because Franklin Richards in the role he
plays the time will come that when the
universe dies Franklin Richards and
Galactus will merge into a singular
being and then be born into the next
universe in whatever form they take but
he's a universal reality warper
even during Hickman's fantastic 420
younger power of Franklin merged with
the older power of his self he still had
enough power to basically resurrect
Galactus from the dead now even then
even if you look outside of that that
scenario you're talking about heroes
reborn we're basically all the different
heroes jumped into onslaught during the
onslaught saga basically everybody but
the x-men and spider-man and they were
all kind of resurrected by Franklin
Richards in a pocket universe he created
that you you literally carry with him as
a blue ball right like he's resurrected
Galactus before during the Abraxas saga
the guy's insanely powerful and for the
x-men to have somebody of that power on
their side is a huge trump card and if
Franklin Richard can't really be
indoctrinated so much as to come to
understand his role among the mutant
population then more likely than not
he'll side with the mutants in whatever
various threats that they're facing and
basically nobody will be able to stop
them if you have a guy who can alter
reality on a universal scale who the
hell is gonna get in your way
so like that's the whole nature of the
power that Franklin possesses and so
it's interesting because the way that
Xavier has been depicted to us over the
course of dawn of X is that he's kind of
nefarious and a lot of that's because of
what's been done by more McTaggart she
was the one who really kind of let him
down this path right but nonetheless the
reason why Kitty Pryde is being called
here is because of the role that Kitty
Pryde played in the early days of
Franklin Richards writing the reason for
that is because I believe at the time
Franklin was part of Power Pack but this
took place during the original x-men vs.
Fantastic Four story and the way this
played out was that Kitty Pryde was in
the process of essentially losing her
ability to become physical right like
she had kind of gone intangible and she
was kind of stuck that way right the
idea was that she was kind of fading
away more or less and initially the the
I think was magneto who was leading the
x-men at the time how to approach Reed
Richards you know in an attempt to
basically try to find a way to cure this
because of some device that Reed
Richards had but not knowing what the
effect was going to be Reed said no and
so what kind of skirmish broke out
ultimately the x-men went to dr. doom in
Latveria and then of course Reed
Richards kind of changed his mind and
they went to went to Liberia and then
basically helped him out and the day was
saved but during that point in time
Kitty Pryde formed a kind of friendship
with Franklin right because in a lot of
ways they were both young they were both
unsure of their powers they were both
unsure of the role that they were
supposed to play it was this notion of
they were kind of new to the world and
they didn't really know what their place
was going to be in the world and so they
kind of found common ground and
camaraderie over
which is a pretty cool concept really
for first the dark skin all of him to
bring back and so ultimately kitty pryde
says yes she ends up siding with it and
saying ok we'll do what we can now the
rest of the x-men are going to show up
but the idea is to send Kitty Pryde
ahead so she can kind of chip away at
Franklin Richards as best you can so
that when the x-men show up and they
asked a question
hoping things go peacefully the
Fantastic Four and the x-men say
Franklin who do you want to go with that
Franklin would choose the x-men rightly
hopefully you know Kitty Pryde can kind
of bridge that or extend that olive
branch and bring him in now of course
she does get a little bit of teasing you
know from from Wolverine you know when
she goes out and more frames like so
you're really gonna do it Han she's like
yeah he's like well good luck cuz he's
basically a young kid full of hormones
who the hell knows what's gonna happen
with him and that's really what it is
right that's really what's going on with
Franklin at the moment is the stories
that took place in Marvel Comics prior
to this when it came to Franklin
Richards kind of gave us this sort of
absolute construct for his character
right insofar as he was so young he'd
really question his parents but he
didn't really question whether or not
what Reed was doing was the right thing
to do Franklin always kind of had this
absolute belief of I'm not gonna
question my parents right they've always
done right by me at this point there's
no reason for me to question that but as
we know when you reach your teenage
years right 13 14 15 years old the role
that you play in this life is is you
look to your parents to kind of give you
a guiding framework right to give you
kind of framework by which you go on
into the war right these are the very
fundamental rules that our parents teach
us in order to understand the idea that
when authority figures tell you to do
something you do it different things
like that don't hurt people so on and so
forth from there we graduate out into
the greater tribe and we try to seek the
approval of our peers and that's when we
take all the lessons our parents have
taught us and we combine them with all
the things that our peers are telling us
and then we kind of come to this sort of
conclusion on what our new moral compass
is going to be the confusion comes into
play when it's like well my friends are
trying to get me to do things that I
don't know if I should do because I'm
here it's told me I shouldn't do it but
my parents say that because they're old
hat by that's where all that kind of
confusion and being young comes into
play and so the bumping of heads and the
pushing of barriers that's where
Franklin Richards is right now and so
the thing that really complicates this
is that his powers are basically
beginning to sort of drain that Franklin
Richards always kind of viewed as this
guy who basically fed off the universe
right he and the universe were almost
kind of part and parcel as long as the
universe existed Franklin Richards could
do his thing but the idea behind this is
in and really what's kind of being
established here with regards to
Franklin's abilities is that there's a
kind of
Yury out there about something called
the god power that every single being
out there right this all comes from a
woman by the name of a Russian account a
Russian a cow cool online you pronounce
that as kou L up but she had have really
kind of theorized and hypothesized this
idea that the god power was kind of this
source of power that exists out there
that different people with extreme
levels of power could tap into right so
somebody like Franklin Richards tapped
into something like the god power right
and so what this did is it kind of
introduced the idea that Franklin is
tapping into an external power source we
just don't know what that is and where
it was believed that external power
source was essentially limitless now it
seems like it's limited it's basically
running out and it's running short and
this is when things really get
interesting because Franklin basically
takes off with Ben Grimm and starts
talking to him really kind of starts
speaking its mind and basically saying
you know when it comes to my dad I look
at the kind of things he's done the kind
of things he said the mental blocks to
be put in place so I wouldn't really be
able to experience the full totality of
my power when I was a little kid of
course those of you guys know I'm
referencing the avatars story where
Franklin Richards had basically been
playing with a Rubik's Cube and he got
frustrated with it and so he used his
powers and solved and not realizing what
he was doing and at that same time there
was a TV commercial that came on and
said what are you gonna grow up and so
subconsciously he aged himself into an
adult with a child's mom didn't really
understand what was going on right so
it's little things like that Franklin in
his early days demonstrated these kind
of extreme abilities but didn't really
know how to control them so in order to
kind of keep himself the world and even
the universe safe Reed Richards put
these mental blocks in his mind so his
powers wouldn't run awry and then
everybody wakes up one morning and every
single human being on the face of the
planet has been turned into like Gumby
that's kind of the thing that Reed was
afraid of and so frankly kind of looked
at that and says given the the history
of my powers and given the fact that my
dad's always really kind of been unsure
of me using my abilities even once we
recreated the multiverse and recreated
you know whole whole universes and and
where my powers were full on my own and
I was in total control of them he always
displayed a kind of unease and they've
always sort of needed your strength so
like what if Reed is kind of you know
even if he's not really intending to
basically shortchanging that's right
like what if he's black following us and
that's the irony of it all because he
did that to Ben from during that exact
same story when Franklin aged himself up
by that old Fantastic Four story
Franklin asked Reed should I change bit
should I give Ben Graham what he wants
and let him go back to being human and
Reed said no it's one of these things
where Reed almost kind of kind of
appears least away this pictures being
painted it's almost kind of being shown
in a way where
he's kind of a dick right like doing
things for his own ends we know that's
not necessarily true but that's kind of
how it looks right and it's not a matter
of what you know it's a matter of how
things look as a result of that with
Kitty Pryde basically showing up
alongside the rest of the x-men of
course it really kind of brings things a
little bit into a panic right because
the first question the Fantastic Four
had is why are you here and Kitty Pryde
being there as well then it's like okay
something's kind of going on and that's
one Xavier and everybody kind of spills
the beans
your son's a mutant and he belongs among
his own mutant people now here's the
important thing to understand Susan
storm flips right she loses her mind
because here comes Xavier and Magneto
right and there they tell mama bear
we're gonna take your baby away and
she's not too happy about that right
like what mom would be okay with a
couple of people showing up on her
doorstep saying like we're gonna take
your child that's kind of crazy ya know
mom would tolerate that and so she
immediately lets loose and is just kind
of like - stay away from my son
following that Xavier steps in and says
we can just take him right like we can
just take your son it'll just be the way
it is you release Magneto or I'll make
you do that and so while this whole
scenario this whole kind of skirmish is
popping off Kitty Pryde grabs Franklin
and they just sort of abscond together
right they just kind of go out there and
they just sort of start talking and this
is really one of the reasons why Kitty
Pryde was brought along from being
honest with you guys it really was kind
of feeding on the the history between
herself and Franklin but it was really
kind of Xavier sort of looking at this
and saying this is most likely what's
gonna happen right like we're showing up
on the doorstep of the Fantastic Four
and telling them you're universally
powerful son is a mutant therefore you
should let him go and he should come
live with us of course you're not gonna
let him go not only because he's their
son but because of the power he
possesses and how they're how everybody
really is kind of afraid of what the
x-men are doing and so realizing that
was most likely what was gonna happen he
deprived was brought along because this
is exactly what would have happened the
Kitty Pryde and really leveler heads
would have prevailed and Katie probably
would have said okay so like let the
saner heads prevail let's just go and
talk unless let's do I think and that's
exactly what happens right now this is
really familiar to the the the
conversation between spider-man and
Franklin after the death of Johnny Storm
during Hickman's run but again it's kind
of like let's just go talk you know and
let's just go kind of have this
conversation she takes him to one of the
Kirk Owen gates and kind of says hey
here's what it looks like and that kind
of a thing and Franklin sort of
interested in it it really seems that
his interest is really more insofar as
let's go check out her Co it and see
what it looks like and then I'll decide
for myself that's one of the things that
I hope you guys are noticing here is
nobody's really asking Franklin what it
is that he wants right people are just
assuming
know what's best for him and the reality
is one his new parents naturally do that
parents naturally kind of come in to say
I know what's best for you because
you're my child and I've been where you
are and that kind of a thing is one of
the disconnects that kind of gets
created between parents and children and
then it's the really Xavier in magneto
being full of hubris well he's a mutant
he belongs with mutants pretty much
every mutant on earth is a krakoa
he needs to be them we know best right
because we're saving the mutant
population but nobody's really asking
him and he's old enough to where he can
be asked that question and be able to
make an intelligent choice and so in the
midst of all this suddenly Johnny Storm
pops up where and Johnny storms like
where the heck have you been everybody's
been looking for you and a fight kind of
breaks out between the two groups and
that's the crazy thing about this is in
reality if I'm being honest with you
guys people are sleeping on Susan storm
if you don't really understand how
powerful she is right like if it comes
down to it Susan storm could kill every
single mutant here like literally create
a force field that just doesn't have any
oxygen inside they'll breathe up all the
oxygen there and they'll suffocate right
or maybe she'll create a force field
inside their head and expand it so their
head explodes right there's an unlimited
number of ways that she can kill
everyone here and so really like the
x-men they're kind of picking a fight
with a pretty dangerous group here right
and so you know as a result of all that
it's one of these things where Franklin
is kind of like I'm tired of all this
I'm gonna make that choice myself I'm
gonna go under the kakuhen gate and when
he passes through nothing happens he
basically runs through one side and out
the other and that's basically it and
the reason for this is really explained
when everybody's kind of like what in
the world is like he should have been
able to pass through when Reed Richards
basically chimes in and essentially says
I modified your body's structure more or
less so that kokoa will not see you as a
mutant so if you decide you wanna pass
through one of these gates it won't work
but like I've made your choice for you
and this is a huge offense to Franklin
because what it shows is that Reed
doesn't believe his son will make the
right choice war Reed does not believe
his son will make the right choice based
on what Reed wants him to do and that's
that's one of the difficult things what
are the most difficult things for a
parent to do is to let their kid go
right to let their kid go out into the
world make mistakes and do things make
their own decisions and become their own
person it's very difficult for a person
for a parent to do what is one of these
things where it has to be done and
that's really what Reed is sort of
facing with right now right like letting
his son go out there and do his thing
and so with this kind of offense having
basically gone down suddenly Franklin's
met with the arrival of Valyria and
valaria makes the right move well she
basically says hey look I can help you
do this right this is what you really
want to do then I can help you get past
all this right I'm as smart as my dad
was I can undo pretty much everything he
did it's one of these funny things where
parents kind of tend to forget that sort
of stuff but what is up happening is we
basically end up picking up with kiddie
priding company while they're out there
you know on the the high seas doing
their thing traveling whatever is there
going only for them to realize that
Franklin and valaria have basically
stowed away not only that the group's
met by the arrival of dr. doom so now
what you have is Franklin Richards whose
powers are draining with the Marauders
and then dr. doom showing up on the
scene it's anybody's guess what's gonna
happen now right like it's pretty
awesome and it's pretty legit and it's
definitely one of these really cool
stories I want to keep that I want to
keep reading and definitely keep
covering for that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained and
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
Bruce
okay I want to give a shout out to Kyle
be David Joseph then john h aj matt in
Jeff are John H lean and mean which is
an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin be Adam
K and Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long it is nothing crazy
but if you want to put a message in
there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson calm and if you're one of
these people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
you